well the glory of watching luis castillo
pitch
he has been simply
sensational
since riding the ship on his season a
couple of months ago
his season-long numbers this is how they
break down over the first 11 versus his
last 11 from western and southern
and you wonder what the difference is
between those first 11 and last 11 and
it's just pitch execution he has been
fantastic
early in the season it was a fastball
changeup combination
but as the season has progressed we've
seen more sliders the fastball slider
combination it's always been fastball
now we're not seeing 95 or 97 we're
seeing 97 to 99 100 miles an hour he's
feeling comfortable and confident out
there happy
nino then
right on the edge called strike three
brent rooker first pitch hot shot ground
ball the well-positioned indian
two down
and here comes the hero from last night
jory polanco
a game-winning shot down the right field
line in the ninth inning off heath
hembree
one two a swinging a blast into right
field and deep this one's back towards
the seats and gone polanco does it again
a first inning two out home run his 18th
one-nothing twins usually the bunches
are a little bit further apart than
about 12 hours he just is so good on
fastballs especially middle to middle in
98 miles an hour down the middle
[Applause]
hard charge suarez bare hand off balance
throw bottle reaches and brings it in
polanco pokes another starting pitcher
stats for charlie barnes here starting
for the twins four and two thirds pretty
good innings i mean
pretty good job for four and two thirds
here's winker
first pitch popped up and in left field
rooker with a long run and he makes the
catch
brent rooker with a diving catch near
the foul line
i don't think he saw the ball well off
the bat it was it fooled him i think he
thought it was further
out than it was then he really had to
close on and make a backhand diving grab
that's a terrific play
[Music]
[Applause]
and a good first inning for charlie
barnes facing just three men pitching
around the lead off single and it's
still one nothing as aquino grounds one
the third one a pick by ryze to his feet
long throwing got him
a bullet hit on the ground to arise at
third went down to get it popped up on
target throw for route number three good
d by rise at third played that
masterfully left in the second hop 2-2
struck him out with the high fastball
downstairs swing of the miss
back-to-back case for castillo and he
retires the top three in order
two on for kyle farmer
farmer scorches one to left wave is on
they'll challenge rooker
[Applause]
farmer given the wave he rips through
third base winker scores farmer scores
delivers
a two-run double and the reds lead three
to one
stevenson pass to rise they're going to
challenge again bottom is wave shallow
left rooker's throw to the plate bottle
slides safely
three straight run scoring hits
four one reds
payoff taken cold strike three
runs with that club swing gonna miss
change up and a good one down and away
from the left-handed hitting larnick and
luis castillo has his seventh strikeout
today
there is abundant patience and selective
aggression from jonathan india it's
easier to plan your defense around that
when a guy's going where he knows he
wants to go
india the left in and out of rooker's
glove akiyama around ford he scores
5-1 cincinnati that's another change out
over the plate and
india does such a nice job and staying
through the baseball rooker
almost gets there
and the speed once again
a couple of walks will bring the
pitching coach out
the 2-2
swung out and missed imported he need
that strikeout
for mania
and there's one away and here's suarez
fastball near the outer edge gets a
swing of the missed two down so two
walks
followed by two swinging strikeouts
today swung on and missed
he struck him out juan manaya pumps his
fist he's excited he struck out three
after a couple of walks that means a
visit derek johnson
is right on this moment with two on and
nobody out the powerful cenote do up
broken back to india backs up
overhand flip farmer pretty spin and
throw
oh beautiful job on the 4-6-3 this was
just well played all around right here
india making the adjustment ball bounds
high
farm
with the pirouette
at shortstop showing off the foot skills
nice strong throw to first base
this could be castillo's last hitter
and it now almost assuredly will be
winker makes the catch
castillo pitches out of trouble from two
on nobody out to no runs and a four-run
lead
tyler stevenson
knocked in a run in the third with a
single
stevenson hits that one fairly well deep
center field
that's going to play
just below the batter's eye tyler
stevenson a long two-out solo
and with two on and nobody out suddenly
cenos up with a chance to really put a
dent in this cincinnati lead
looks like he's going to get another
change up here
that's to the right field corner and
down for a hit it'll beat aquino to the
wall
polanco will score
and
sono to second with a double
two strikeouts again today
[Music]
and that's a fair ball down the line he
delivers the hit
a rise will score
and larnick into second with a double
and the twins have already struck
for three runs here in the eighth inning
strokes it solidly to left field a
hanging breaking ball larnik scores and
it's a one-run game
2-2
swing in the miss he struck around
so no double play ball farmer fumbles
finds india the first double play
the reds win it
lorenzo bolts it down and they split the
series a 6-5 finish